con imágenes impactantes proporcionadas
por la televisión estatal norcoreana que
documentan el lanzamiento de un misil
balístico intercontinental pero no es
uno cualquiera se trata de agua son 17
apodado el misil monstruo un nombre que
se ha ganado por su capacidad de ser
equipado con ojivas nucleares y por su
autonomía puede alcanzar los 15 mil
kilómetros así tendría la capacidad de
golpear cualquier parte de eeuu en este
vídeo el propio kim jong-un ordena el
lanzamiento y recuerda a la comunidad
internacional su presencia en un momento
en que todas las miradas están puestas
en ucrania
o corea del norte está tratando de
volver a centrar la atención sobre sí
misma o piensa que como estamos tan
preocupados en este momento ellos van a
sufrir menos repercusiones en mí
esta es la primera vez en más de cuatro
años que se dispara un dispositivo de
tipo balístico aunque corea del norte
nunca ha dejado de disparar misiles de
corto y medio alcance
el lanzamiento del misil de largo
alcance supone el riesgo de una escalada
de detenciones importantes en la región
el ex secretario general insta a corea
del norte a no emprender más acciones
contraproducentes octiv actions en la
escena internacional pyongyang podría
contar con el apoyo de moscú corea del
norte fue uno de los cinco países que
votaron en contra de la resolución de la
onu que condenaba la agresión rusa en
ucrania así que se puede esperar que
rusia lo recuerde y que mete cualquier
resolución del consejo de seguridad que
pidan nuevas sanciones